we enter completely our own world
the prisoner of azkaban is one of the
best harry potter movies
but it's also when things started
getting serious
on set things were more lighthearted the
actors pulled pranks on each other
and emma watson had fun punching tom
felton even though it wasn't
in the script how did they pull off such
a dark film and turn it into a blast
behind the scenes
let's find out lumos maxima
this lumo scene at the beginning of the
third movie had some fans questioning
wizarding world
rules wouldn't harry get in trouble for
using charms outside of school
but regardless filming the scene was fun
and a bit sweaty i wouldn't touch that
it's very wet
harry seems to be in his own private
cocoon but on set
daniel had director alfonso quran
telling him what to do
under that blanket he was sitting on
this illuminated platform that had him
feeling a bit warm
and technicians were controlling the
light from his wand
hermione punching draco will forever go
down in harry potter history is one of
the most satisfying moments of the
series
but according to tom felton the scene
wasn't supposed to include a punch at
all
actually originally said in the script
that hermione uh slaps draco
the punch idea came when both actors
decided they wanted to add a little
intensity to the scene
apparently emma has a pretty good punch
and she enjoyed every minute of it
emma was looking forward for that moment
harry potter
might be the chosen one but even he's
not above getting pranked
by his professors for this scene in the
great hall
michael gambon and alan rickman teamed
up to put a fart machine in daniel
radcliffe's sleeping bag
so it would go off while filming not
even dumbledore could keep a straight
face
making harry invisible takes a lot of
cgi and a green cloak
which can be a bit hard to take
seriously in this scene
they used string to get ron's hat and
hermione's hair to move
but the actors had trouble not cracking
up when daniel
threw off his green cloak and popped in
just like three kids having a snow day
that was not funny the first person who
ever really made daniel feel starstruck
on set
was gary oldman but isn't it fitting
that daniel looked up to the actor
playing his on-screen godfather the two
ended up developing a bond similar to
sirius and harry's
daniel also had this to say about movies
three and five
which he thinks were his best
performances i think that is
in part to do the fact that i have gary
oldman around
speaking of sirius black sirius's
disheveled look for the movies
included wild hair a grungy beard and
those awesome
nordic inspired tattoos even though his
body art was never mentioned in the
books
alfonso quran and gary oldman decided to
make the character
theirs i look like i've escaped from
prison don't you don't you think
oldman came up with sirius's hairstyle
while kiran designed all the tattoos
himself
as director alfonso quran came up with a
lot of the film's vision
even though he had never even read the
series before getting hired
working with kids definitely had his
challenges he had a swear jar to try and
keep himself from cursing in front of
the young cast
but he still had a great time on set i
was always be going to him you know how
should i do it just tell me what to do
you go no
you've got you've got to do it yourself
he helped get the young actors where
they needed to be emotionally
and he even let them improvise some of
their lines like in this scene
where he encourages emma to follow her
instincts if it helps
keep it the final design for the
dementors was
also heavily influenced by koran the
crew tried a lot of different techniques
to get them right
like having them on strings then
puppeteered in the water
before they finally settled on cgi i was
a little hesitant about cg so i wanted
to do everything old school
it's the slow movement extra long cloaks
and layers of fabric that end up making
the final result
so perfect isn't he beautiful
say hello to buckbeak prisoner of
azkaban introduced us to
care of magical creatures and buckbeak
but creating the hippogriff behind the
scenes was both fun
and challenging the animatronic model
really moves and was made of hand-cut
and painted feathers it took a huge team
four and a half months to create
three of them for filming check out
daniel riding this motion raygun set so
they could later finish the scene with
cgi
alfonso quran seems to be full of good
advice and always knows exactly what to
tell his actors to get a good
performance
one tip he gave daniel was to picture
his celeb crush
cameron diaz in a bikini during scenes
like this
when he needed to look shocked or taken
aback and it worked
another fun fact is that emma watson's
crush was actually on set with her
she admitted she had a bit of a thing
for tom felton he was a few years older
and he had a skateboard rupert grant
loved feeling like a family while
filming the movies
but he admits it felt a little
suffocating at times he even compared it
to
groundhog day because it felt like
coming back and doing the same thing
over and over again
he revealed on the armchair expert
podcast that prisoner of azkaban was
actually the very last
harry potter film he ever watched and
he's never continued past that point
daniel has also admitted to having some
issues with anxiety
and getting used to fame but he doesn't
regret his experience
everyone always expects me to not want
to talk about it or anything but like i
you know i really don't mind as for emma
she almost did a very hermione-like
thing
and quit when she was 16 to focus on her
education
during the first few movies the cast had
to do their homework on set between
takes
and even at their hogwarts desks but for
the third movie the director decided to
merge their homework and character study
together
there's a famous story about quran
assigning the trio to each complete an
essay about their character of course
emma did the most by writing an amazing
paper
well daniel did the bare minimum and
rupert didn't finish his at all
that's how please i've done it i've done
it i've done it so i have my the next
diamond comes in with all 16 pages of
hers
being in school also made their
schedules pretty crazy each day when
filming was done they had to go to
tutoring
everybody go off to lovely school this
whomping willow scene was fun to film
and maybe just a
bit dangerous emma hopped on a fake
branch to be swung around
but most of the close-up shots of the
duo escaping were accomplished by having
the camera
act as a branch itself it was a fun
high-speed scene to film
but all expertly choreographed lupin
transforming into a werewolf in the
movie
is impressive sure but it's even more
impressive watching him transform behind
the scenes
there were a lot of prosthetics involved
watching himself become
unrecognizable was uh exciting they
filmed half the scene before putting him
in makeup
and then continued as he was turning
they also had to create
this very convincing werewolf suit we're
in the shrieking shack
aren't we for scenes in the shrieking
shack the crew didn't just rely on cgi
instead they built an actual moving
frame
so that it would seem like the shack was
swaying and creaking while the actors
were inside
but it was also a lot safer than filming
in a real abandoned building
welcome to the night bus emergency
transport for the stranded witch or
wizard
did you know that the night bus is
actually a real bus and they really
drove it around london
check out these quick turns and all the
swaying that would definitely make
passengers a little queasy
a double-decker bus didn't cut it so
instead they took a normal bus and
cut it in half lifted it then added a
middle section
and drove it around the city here you
can see the interior scenes being filmed
on a sound stage using a hydraulic
moving platform
peter pettigrew is a sinister villain
sure
he might not be the brightest or the
most terrifying but he did put
voldemort's plans into action
however it's not nearly as easy to take
him seriously behind the scenes
especially when sirius tries to get his
revenge on a fake
rat but we gotta say the actual rat
actor
who plays scabbers that's pretty cute
you're alive prisoner of azkaban
actually gave a lot of animal actors
their big breaks
especially these surprisingly
well-behaved crows and bats
they were trained by the film's animal
trainer gary garrow
but it was definitely difficult to get
them go where they needed to at all
times
and for the young actors to get used to
all the fluttering around their heads
while they were trying to remember their
lines
another interesting fact crookshanks
whose real name is cracker jack by the
way
has such nice fur that they had to add
these clumps to it before filming
have some jelly and put it on his eyes
to make them look all weepy
so he's not so handsome what about the
cast that
almost was hogwarts almost had a
different headmaster
with both of these white wizards sir ian
mckellen
and sir christopher lee being considered
to play dumbledore in the third film
but it was richard harris who passed
away after playing dumbledore in the
first two films
who ultimately had the final say he
wasn't a big fan of mckellen's
so the actor decided out of respect not
to take the role
christopher lee was focusing more on
playing villains at the time so he
passed too
instead we got michael gambin who
brought the perfect amount of wisdom and
charisma to scenes like
these and he had a good time doing it
happiness can be found
even in the darkest of times prisoner of
azkaban was filmed on location in
scotland where it rained
for 28 days straight sets were
constantly being washed out
the actors had to be followed around
with umbrellas and they even had to use
helicopters like this one to
fly in gravel to fill in areas that had
been wiped away by all the water
but one perk to all that rain was that
it created a constantly gloomy and gray
tone which ended up being
perfect for the movie it was phenomenal
we had this soft grey
overcast scottish light prisoner of
azkaban really does look like it was the
most fun to film
do you agree we wonder if rupert will
ever watch the rest of the series
but we understand it's gotta be crazy
having your childhood years immortalized
in film
besides for sure the cast has enough
magical memories from their harry potter
days to last a lifetime